right it's a ride and it's based on
the of course fine film
franchise michael cinematic series of
cinematic masterpieces known as
uh the fast and the furious franchise uh
so the um if you're walking through that
the the whole line going in is like dude
it was garage
it was sick did you see all the cars in
there
bro it was sick like they had all these
sick
dope cars sick
you name a single one of those cars
[ __ ] a honduran
horse is not a car guys something
super charger bro i'll tell you this
zx 0zx something right they all had nos
they weren't even functioning
automobiles
just they were just shells of cars so
when when you go on the when you go on
this you know what we could do mike
here we go so people could really when
you go on this ride and you will
look we almost wrote it all again no oh
no so it's the whole ride
um oh no so you go on this ride oh god
and i guess someone's doing a pov of it
this is what it looks like on the
outside
fast and the furious supercharged cause
you know they're they got like these uh
the garage is in like one of these old
city buildings you know
right so normally not look this is
here's the thing mike normally they have
this little interactive section you know
you saw those guys with the headphones
that we walk by
when there's a lot of people normally
it's a little show like this party
busters the lights
yeah i'm not gonna lie i don't like the
kid we got because he was smug
yeah he was he was one of us that was
like chewing gum and he was trying to be
cool guy
you know he reminded me that [ __ ] he
reminded me the assistant pro
what is it the uh the production
assistant
on a set just smarmy little [ __ ] faces
yeah so
this is uh these are some of the cool
videos that you missed
all right i want you to keep in mind
this is totally not a cgi ludicrous they
actually got ludicrous bye man
why mia all right pat let's get these
people on their way
send them over to the wall room got it
boss peace
so they interact with these pre-recorded
videos the people there
and it's it's it's somebody said
somebody said with this guy somebody
says man tyrese looks like [ __ ]
no that's not tyrese that's a employee
of universal
uh so then you walk to the other room hi
there's a lot of you
okay uh my name is jamie as you may know
this is my first day by myself
so they have to stay in character it's
really good now mike you got lucky you
didn't get to see any of this stuff
because there was no line the line was
just empty because everyone's doing the
houses
so when you get on the ride uh the ride
is a party bus
is that what it could be described as a
party no they call it that
but we i wasn't feeling it was a party
bus
it felt like a shuttle royce it felt
like a shuttle in an amusement park
party shuttle it wasn't very immersive
you get on
party bus and then you start moving at
an incredible rate of speed
of the us diplomatic security service
and u.s
diplomatic yes security center the u.s
diplomatic security service has been in
our country for a long time
are you saying these men aren't heroes
that sounds like a private company
operated by the government wait um
are you saying these men aren't heroes
mike
look i'm not saying that dwayne the rock
johnson
isn't a hero is that who that was it's
such good acting
he just he was immersed in that role
also under armour commercial it was i
had to say
i was talking about this on night wave
last night
the entire it was all right going there
whatever i hate lines i hate haunted
houses i hate that whole spiel
it was worth the entire cost of the
ticket for this ride for this road no
i'm not even kidding like unironically
trying to explain to them last night
that unironically it was worth a
70 ticket to go on this ride
it's sometimes something's bad and you
go this is just bad
subjectively bad i got no joy we got so
much joy
from the fast and furious ride because
of how bad the people around us were mad
because they were there on ironic one
point mike was howling
i mean he was oh no i was
you to see because you had your head
down because mike to be fair was trying
to i was trying
i wasn't even you see the guys in front
of you like
and i no and i really what like this one
i wasn't doing it as a bit where you're
like
like royce is right i was actually
trying to like no
no i was i was dying that people were
just like this is so rude
so that every time they would say family
i would say
as loud as i could in the back there was
actual when you're walking up right
you know what i forgot the coolest part
it's a really cool part when vin diesel
is hanging from the helicopter in a very
obvious city
but then he's he's driving the car on
one side of the party and he's going
hey make sure you keep the widows alive
and then he jumps out of the car
and then on this side he's hanging from
a helicopter
reminding us once again to keep the
witness alive then royce
he's back in the car [ __ ] no problems
you think that's the best part but the
best part was was the totally uh
totally normal rave where they all had
to stay dance right next to each other
and it was all the fbi agent that we're
gonna get on the show and they also
played the uh
they played it on two screens but before
the tram had made it so i could see the
identical scenes it was
oh so and then i you know what i love i
love a quickly thrown together
dance party scene oh we'll get to that
you know what's up and as of 16.9
seconds ago
i'm the man in charge no he's in charge
what must have happened universal
studios he's in charge yeah he owns it
high value witness from the federal
protection program aboard your vehicle
an international crime syndicate led by
owens i'm sorry
i'm sorry um general rock
um wouldn't wouldn't the u.s marshall
service at that point
have jurisdiction over the
transportation of this federal prisoner
i i'm gonna ask you one question i'm not
an expert
i'm asking a question i'm gonna answer
for you man i mean i'm gonna answer your
question with
with a question okay have you seen his
vest
okay look royce i'll admit that i'm
basing
most of my knowledge on federal law
enforcement uh jurisdictions
on the four or five or so seasons of
justified that i watched but i'm almost
70 certain that the u.s marshals service
would be handling this but
that should be railing not the u.s
special diplomatic
council you said the name wrong on
purpose to be fun
jaw is honing in on this vehicle to take
that witness out well then why don't you
call
in the i don't know the federal
government something else that i think i
think i think
our buddy eric who's in the chat you
know he pointed it out he was like
man he's really giving it his all in
this scene
this is one of those he got rock got a
paycheck
they filmed this on the set of the last
fast movie is what they did
yeah they just they tell you like look
you're getting [ __ ] 30 million for
this picture but you're gonna have to do
a whole bunch of other peripheral [ __ ]
that you're gonna hate
he just wants to go home same reason why
you see them all just show up on like a
a list of [ __ ] like all this they
have an itinerary set for them of all
the shows they're going to go on to do
press and stuff that's all part of your
that's part of your already paycheck bud
you need to go out and do that as part
of your already paycheck so after the
rock leaves
your cell phones the party tram gets
moving and you see
all of these sick cars look how sick
that
it's a is is it does it say yeah do you
are you looking at the stickers
sick so then you go through this area
here it is so um i love i love a quickly
thrown together
small party scene that they have to when
you have to film and everybody has to
just
fake dance and nobody there's nobody
actually having fun it doesn't look
like you know what if you're noticing a
movie when they
really are filming a good club scene and
you go wow they're all right yeah they
really
and then there's times where you're like
all right we need uh 25 good looking
people
stand there look like you're dancing hey
yeah let's get this done please we got
ludacris for another 10 minutes
so um when you pull up this this is
this set is like this there's this
screen
and it's i don't want to say a hologram
but it's like the video's overlaid on
over a real set
yeah behind it so they're in a warehouse
having one of those typical warehouse
parties man it's a good thing that all
they needed was one fbi agent
since they were all standing right next
to each other and it's weird how they
all just got out in such an orderly way
yeah but wait a second mike
this is what we're doing this is that's
tyrese
they're having coronas can i ask that's
the boy's drink
yes did tyrese miss the massive federal
raid that was going on right in front of
him two seconds like
i mean the fbi came to stop a rape
somebody said in the chat yeah the fbi
didn't put up with that but then the fbi
with all their full forces right they
showed in and they
in a show of force they raid this rave
but tyrese is is two feet behind the fed
and he doesn't notice
any cat now he hasn't noticed anything
amiss to be fair he's just a singer i
mean what do you want the guy
they broke up that party very quickly
roy very quickly i would say
this is when mike was laughing
uncontrollably when roman pearce showed
up
this was no fbi this was one of the
parts
yes this was one of the parts this was
the part where i got very squeaky and i
was trying not to laugh
first off that shirt's really wrinkled
tyrese rest right now
face this back up a little bit
lightweight first of all i don't work
for you oh really
well the guy has a gun on you and it's
very clearly a rubber gun
it's not even a prop gun it's so you
know what i mean like you see some prop
guns sometimes you're like oh that looks
legit this is a rubber gun
what do you work for uh-oh we don't work
for nobody
without that suggestion so what would
have happened if they needed to come up
and the rave was still going on would
they have killed all those people
i guess yeah because they would have
just fell into the ground yeah i just
fell on the ground and just got stuck
there's years yeah it would have been
very ugly
so then van diesel comes up from some
sort of remarkable
elevator under the ground with a
modified
semi truck yes batman's armory the joker
gave it to me
and michelle rodriguez is there a clear
idea otherwise we can't guarantee you
yeah this show rodriguez who's a lesbian
but has to play straight to make money
in this franchise
yep and it has to drive her crazy she's
like a reverse anthony clark
if the thing is with with ven diesel
like if you look how he's dressed a
white shirt with the cross and
and the diesel jeans he's dressed like
2003 the person he is but he never
like everybody else like imagine if the
rock was still dressing with the [ __ ]
versace shirts and the gold chains and
people be like where she was i know any
pack
yes but but but ven diesel just he's
like
this is this isn't like his character
this is van diesel
yeah you're right though i'm trying to
imagine now
and not even like turtleneck rock but
the rock you're describing when he was
in the corporate when he was yeah for
that that would be the rocks version of
just 2002.
he kept doing it if he just kept doing
it if we still had frosted tips in the
metal ball necklaces i mean that's
pretty much
and also vendison only works out his
glory muscles
guarantee my safety i'm the one holding
the gun are you though
yeah the line's a whole lot bigger than
yours yeah i get it but he has okay why
are they all here though
why is the rock's special forces
diplomatic
command the camera frame can only catch
so much why is he also involved in
busting up raves
what's you don't get it bro okay look
why are they all here
you missed a plot it's a d-plot this is
such a what a coincidence that they're
all here
listen to the you don't miss you missed
the plot you weren't paying attention
because you were too busy making fun of
it
we took the the why are they all there
royce the department of federal security
which the rock works for clearly uh
diplomatic diplomatic department of
security whatever
i had to look shut up don't [ __ ]
don't don't explain to me as i explained
the plot to you no i'm listening
okay so there was these ages like so so
there was this agent right and one of
them is the mcpoyles
no that's not one of those points we
looked this guy up and i but after this
ride
we actually sat outside for a second i
needed to know and we looked up who this
actor was the fbi agent because he was
the weakest actor on the screen and
that's saying a lot yeah when you're the
weakest actor on that screen and vin
diesel's there
this is your moment to shine yeah this
is your moment to outshine
a bunch of terrible actors that are more
famous than you
um escort does not miss out
go cookie [ __ ] got an ugly suit on man
it's cheap
somebody out there really pissed off
shop it's gonna get up
but don't move from the semi truck
because the rock and ven diesel didn't
actually film this scene together
because in real life they can't stand
each other
who's shaw which one shaw's rock
okay shaw's there's a rock in this i
believe
i'm going off of that because he did the
movie with jason stacy some statham
hobbs and shaw and i don't see jason
statham there so it has to be shaw's the
rock
okay and then it's tyrese and then i
don't know their names bro
this is so bad i'm going to assume mike
this is
wait no shaw's jason state wait no
they're saying shaw's jason say okay
guys look i'm not gonna lie to you
mike and i [ __ ] around and we we pretend
we love fast and furious because we want
brendan shaw to like us
but in reality we've never i don't
really
keep up with this universe i am this is
my preferred universe
hobbes is the rock i can go back like
michelle rodriguez seems hung over for
this
all the people i went to high school
with
that would be renting this out of a red
box because they love it
so much if i went back in time i'd be
able to like
point at every kid and tell you which
one it's going to be
if that kid's going to grow up sleeping
on a mattress on the floor and he's
gonna love renting
fast and furious movies from redbox it's
just such a
it's a certain demographic that likes
these that's right you know that's
those are the people that watch the move
those these movies are the people that
still use red boxes it's exactly the
type of people
that look man it's easy to make fun of
because it's terrible but they're a
movie nine and they still
[ __ ] make so much money doing insane
money insane money
yeah don't worry lucky for you our whole
family will protect you
okay that was heavily yeah what royce
got wrong was
this was the point where i started
making
dude the noises i was making
could only be described as like imagine
if you were a butcher
and you went to slaughter a pig but you
[ __ ] up
and you ended up cutting the pig's neck
but not killing it
it was that was the kind of noise
i was making and genuinely trying to
hold it in not trying to disrupt the
ride
but genuinely trying to keep it in and i
was like
as soon as he went yeah
[Music]
all i know was we messed with i
just was like i i [ __ ]
can't do this
and that's when royce as royce pointed
out i was
doubled over and laughing and going
howling please please i don't want
anybody to notice me and i said and we
were on the back of the party bus
so everybody up front had to go
everyone's looking back at me and i'm
like yeah
[ __ ] you there's no line go on it again
without me
uh lucky for you a whole family of
protections
that got lucky for you and he's not even
responding to
her or him sounds [ __ ] none of these
people are in the same room on the same
day
lucky for you a whole family
i was like yeah i can't he can't do this
the phone just rang that was very fast
how did they show up
not only that but again vin diesel's
range
well it looks like he chased us we'll
have to go
into the other room now
it was dude i couldn't i can't with this
so then then the car
and no cell phones and keep very quiet
[Music]
here we go here it is
oh and look something you don't see
there you actually feel the heat
because they're making you feel like
you're all right
it's not because this used to be the
earthquake ride and this was the
earthquake scene where there was fire
and stuff and they just reused a lot of
the mechanics and put it in to be honest
with you the earthquake thing was always
cooler yeah of course oh i'll give you
100 because it was like practical
effects
they bring that back can they bring back
the earthquake ride um you're in the
subway tunnel that falls apart in this
flooding starts happening
no that's where this ride took over
that's why they were just trying to
reuse the
mechanics that they had that they spent
all this money on
this is our turn that's his turf
here we go we're we're going on this
party bus
we found him so quick with all these
truck mounted machine guns
i'm just waiting for my favorite part
so they they they hook the party box up
to these
by the way i can't they repurpose this
as the el chapo prison transport
simulator now that would
el chapo junior transport prison
transport simulator 2000.
and so you gotta understand is a lot of
these things if you look at some of
these people sometimes they're act you
gets the actors filming some things but
so it's just terrible cgi
so
basically i don't know why there's wind
noises either because you're not you're
not actually moving in this part
these are just screens around you
so then they just straight up kill this
guy
that guy's dead uh and now here it comes
there's a real totally real helicopter a
couple of them
why is the wind that's so funny yeah
there he is
that's ven diesel he's hanging on a
helicopter and not only is he hanging on
a helicopter you can hear clearly what
he's saying
then he flies around to the other side
and you do a jump this is the cool jump
the bus lands from the song
i know from his song yeah i know he has
a song called active
well after we got off the ride we were
actually going should we just write it
again
i feel like we missed stuff it was
i'm glad you found that video because i
was trying to convey this story to these
people last night and i couldn't
i was not doing it any justice
again it was work because i when i told
them how much it costs to go to
halloween horror nights people were like
are you [ __ ] serious
i'm like yeah and you just stand in
lines i was telling them about all the
bored employees and all that
oh yeah yeah take you out of it there's
really no
point to go other than the
overall cool aesthetic you're just
walking around and it's spooky and fun
like
if you if you ever liked halloween for
any moment of your life as a kid
it's cool to go as an adult and drink
adult drinks
and and eat [ __ ] a krusty burger
while you look at weird [ __ ] smoking
people
but like a lot of it is corny and i was
telling them i'm like you don't
understand
that it was worth every penny in war the
minute we got off that ride i was like
that was
my night's not going to get better
that's a really good ride oh and then i
was telling them about how your wife
kept pointing out the uh
they can't go they can't uh they can't
break character until they get
completely off the ground so you can
actually see
like some guy going burn and some guy
coming off break and going up to another
zombie and being like
yo derek it's your turn all right yeah i
got you dude
with a chainsaw and the other one's
going murr
in the corner
yeah baby uh-huh no i i told you i was
gonna be working late tonight yeah i
know
i know i got time for one cigarette and
a pepsi i gotta go right back in
okay all right i will call you i promise
i ain't [ __ ] with that girl i promise
all right click and then it was
going back somebody says wait crusty
burgers are real i thought that's a real
thing yeah
see in in the universal they have a
simpsons land that actually has a krusty
burger
and it has a it has a mohs and the mohs
is pretty cool they did a pretty good
job making it look like moe's that
bartender wanted to keep oh my god yeah
mike walks over can you imagine being a
bartender here in a simpsons
and he was like an older irish guy like
you could just tell did not want it he
wanted he wants to be at a place like
you know
called oh murtaugh's that has like you
know old firefighter hats on the wall or
some [ __ ] do you know what i mean and
he's a
piece of [ __ ] moe's i felt [ __ ]
bad for him you know he took that job
and he was like
yeah moe's like oh yeah like southwest
grill and he got there and he was like
just nothing from the cartoon cartoon it
was very funny
that [ __ ] fast and furious and then
watching the zombies go on break